Fox News faces growing legal troubles
just a week after firing star anchor
Bill O'Reilly 11 current and former
employees filed a class-action lawsuit
they claim 21st Century Fox Fox News
executive vice president Diane Brandee
and former comptroller Judith Slater
subjected minorities in the company to
quote abhorrent intolerable unlawful and
hostile racial discrimination the suit
expands on discrimination suit fired by
two planes last month it's one of two
filed against the company yesterday in a
statement to CBS News Fox News says the
company and Diane brandy quote
vehemently denied the race
discrimination claims in both lawsuits
they are copycat complaints of the
original one filed last month we will
vigorously defend these cases CBS News
legal analyst Ricky Clement is here
Ricky good morning good morning your
assessment of these suits I think that
when you read these suits particularly
the one filed in the state court in the
runs you actually get a pain to your gut
the allegations and we must remember
their allegations show a systemic
pervasive problem in Fox News culture we
have been thinking of it as the powers
that be
first there was Roger Ailes he gets how
stood that domino falls and moves us to
Bill O'Reilly that domino falls but
we're dealing with sex so it never
dawned on us that we might also be
dealing with race so crisis creates
opportunity you got rid of two of the
biggest powers there and you had first
there were two and then there were seven
and then there were nine and now there's
11 people in a class action this class
action has incredible potential to
really hurt Fox News bottom why so well
when you look at the amount of money
involved you're here in New York State
and New York City which have some of the
toughest anti-discrimination laws no
caps punitive damages a very very simple
burden of proof of good faith belief
what are the allegations the allegations
are that there was a woman named Judas
later she's the Comptroller she
is the witch as she is portrayed of
FoxNews in a pounding payroll so what
Judas later allegedly did for years and
years would subject people of color
black people people who had dark skin to
insults to deep to there were things of
that that were said that actually turn
your stomach she even got to the point
where she would have allegedly black
people wrestle arm wrestle as if the
sport back in the Jim Crow days so what
you've got are is a misunderstanding of
how arm wrestle white female supervisors
for entertainment correct entertainment
let's applaud and let's see who is the
strong person the black are the white
you how so and I can't resist it there
is one plaintiff who talks about the
fact that she had breast cancer and she
is demeaned about the size of her
breasts and when you read those
allegations you just go this can't
possibly have existed but yet they say
it did Ricky when we talk about Judith
Kampf Judas later the for the
Comptroller she was fired earlier this
year her attorney called the lawsuits
meritless and frivolous and said all
claims of racial discrimination against
Miss later are completely false is it
meaningful that she was her employment
at Fox was terminated of course and it's
meaningful for both sides Fox is going
to say hey look we just found out as
soon as we found out we got rid of the
wrongdoer we got rid of Judas later
plaintiffs will say hey wait a minute
this is the tip of the iceberg it wasn't
just you later when we complained we
were put down we were it was all covered
up we were not allowed to go up the
chain Rickey claiming good to have you
here thank you thanks Ricky